Now that we have a basic overview of, you know,
the different types of animation in the engine,
how to preview them,
and a very basic understanding of the flow of logic
of how the animations might be triggered,
we're going to jump into the engine
and take a look at creating our own animation.
So for that, we'll be using Sequencer and Control Rig.
And we'll also see how we can attach something
to our character and save this out
as a new animation for your project.
We'll be working in Sequencer to create our animation.
So this is where you'll be working
if you want to create a new animation
or edit an existing one in engine.
Now Sequencer is the cinematic tool of Unreal Engine.
And you can use this for creating
and previewing any cinematic sequences that you might have.
So you can add your characters, your cameras,
your effects and lighting.
You can even set up different events and logic
to trigger in the sequence.
Basically just about anything you need for your cinematic,
which you can play in real time,
or you can even render out a video
to use outside of the engine.
Now we do have dedicated courses for Sequencer.
So if there's something you want to learn a bit more about,
then definitely check those out
because we're only really gonna
scratch the surface today.
So for now, we're going to look
at adding a character to the sequence,
see how you can animate with Control Rig,
and then blend some existing animations together
to create a new animation
and see how we can save that out
as its own animation sequence
that you can use in the project.
So first thing we want to do
is create our level sequence.
So we find just an empty space
in your content browser and right click,
come up to cinematics,
then choose level sequence.
And then it'll ask you to rename it.
So I'll just call it my level sequence.
And we can just double click this to open it up.
And this is our Sequencer window right here.
Now this is where you'd be adding your characters
or your lighting, your effects,
whatever it might be that you need for your sequence.
And to add stuff to your sequence,
we can do that in two different ways.
So we could hit the add button here
and choose add actor to sequence.
And what that will do is it'll filter out
everything that you've got
in your current level that you had open
and allow you to add it to your sequence.
Now what this does,
it will create a hard reference
between the sequence and the level
and connect the two of them together.
So that next time you open this level,
or rather next time you open the sequence,
you will also need to have the level open.
Now, the other way we can add something to the sequence
is by just grabbing it from the content browser
and dragging it into the sequence.
So that's what I'm gonna do in this case,
because what it does is it means
when you open the sequence,
it will spawn that asset that I've just dragged in
and it'll reference it from the content browser
rather than from the actual level that you have open.
So that means we could use this sequence
in any other level that we have in the engine.
Now, notice when we dragged our character into the sequence
our actual layout mode changed inside the engine here.
So with this dropdown menu, we have a few different modes
and essentially they are different layouts
that give us access to, I guess, context sensitive
windows and tools that are available
for the different modes.
So when you add a character to a sequence,
it automatically puts you into animation mode.
Now this will give you access to, you know,
some animation friendly tools
that you're probably familiar with
if you've animated before.
So we've got things like poses and tweens
and snapper up here.
So if you want to save any poses for your character,
you can do that with the poses tool.
You can then tween your poses as well
with this little tool down here
and change how the tweener works.
You've also got the snapper.
So this will allow you to snap two objects together
or snap one object to the location,
the transforms of another.
You can see motion trails here as well.
And you've got all the different motion trail settings
that you could edit in here.
You've also got animation layers.
I'm just going to turn that off,
which is a relatively new addition
in the animation mode tab here.
So if you've got any layers that you want to add
when you're animating, you would do that through here.
And this is how you manage them as well.
And you've also got a really handy tool here
that creates a temporary pivot
for whatever you have selected.
So if you want to change where something sort of rotates
from, this is a really useful tool for that.
You also see that we've got the animation outliner here.
So as you would in your, you know, in mayo or blender,
you can select your controls from this window here.
And you can see the animation details
just on the right hand side
for anything you've got selected.
So inside the sequencer window, we have our character
and just below our character,
we've got one of the control rigs
that came in automatically with it.
So if I was to open that and select any of the assets,
you can see that in the details panel here,
whatever we've got selected updates.
So I'm just going to dock our sequencer window here
so that we can see our character in the viewport here
and essentially start animating.
It's really that easy to get started.
So we can grab our controls here
and start posing our character up if we want to.
Now, when you're animating in sequencer,
there are two very useful things to know.
So that would be how to set a key
and then also how to turn on auto key
so that every time you make a change,
sequence is going to set a key for you automatically.
So we can set a key in two different ways.
We could select any of our controls here
and we could set a little plus that adds a key
at the current time,
or you can actually just use S,
which is the shortcut on the keyboard.
So I could select several here and press S
and then drag the timeline along, press S again,
and you'll see that adds new keys
for the ones we have selected.
Now, auto key is just this little blue icon here.
So currently for us, it's turned on.
So if I was to come over here,
select this upper arm and make a change,
you'll see that we automatically get a new key.
That's turned off.
That's not going to happen when I make a change.
And what happens if I scrub through,
you'll see that that change isn't kept.
It only remembers the previous key.
So that may or may not be on by default.
So if it's not, be sure to just toggle it on.
And then anytime you make a change,
it'll save that there for you and set a new key.
I'm just going to highlight these and delete them.
Now to set a key for all of the controls
in our control rig,
I'm just going to scroll back up to the top
and on the name of the control rig essentially here,
I'm just going to hit,
tell you what, let's do it at frame zero.
Just going to hit the plus
to add a new key at the current time.
And you see that as we scrub down,
that's added a key for everything we've got
or every control that we have in the control rig.
So let's make a quick animation here
of our mannequin just waving.
So I'm going to scrub along a little bit
because I've got auto key turned on,
just means that I can scrub along
and grab the controls and just make a new pose.
So he's going to bring his arm up here
and then if I scrub along a little further,
bring it up a little higher,
maybe even bring the clavicle up a little bit
and he's going to wave.
So currently my manipulator handle,
my rotation control here, my gizmo,
is set into object mode.
So we can change that or local space rather.
We can change that to world space
with this icon just up here.
So I know this is breaking the elbow,
but just from our perspective,
I'm going to do that so it's a little easier
for us to get this wave done.
So you can just click this
and toggle between local or world space.
So if we come across here
and then go left and right and left,
we've got a little wave for our character.
And then what I'll do
is I'll get him to bring his hand back down.
So if I select all the controls that we've animated,
I'm just going to press S to set a key to keep this pose.
And then I'm going to highlight these first keys,
press control C to copy them,
and then drag over to our last frame,
press control V and it'll paste those in.
Oh, actually that's not the case for the clavicle,
is it?
Control C, control V.
Yeah, it seems like I forgot to select that one.
Oh, forgot to copy paste that one.
So as you can see now, as we scrub through,
the hand comes up, does a wave and goes back down.
If I just play that, we can see our character waving.
Let's say we were happy with this animation
and we want to save it out as its own animation sequence.
So we're not relying on the sequencer to play it
and the control rig that we have here.
And then once we've got that,
we can use that in any sort of animation logic
that we might have to trigger this animation
during the game or whenever we want to trigger it.
So if I scrub back to the top of our sequence
and select our character mesh, our skeletal mesh mani,
I'll right click and choose bake animation sequence.
Now this will just ask you where you want to save it
and what do you want to call it?
And we'll just call it A underscore wave
and I'll just put it in the content browser base folder.
And that also gives us some extra options
to either tick or untick when we're saving this.
This will be different every time,
depending on what you've got on your character.
So if you've got more targets you want to export with it
or any curves on your bones that you want to export,
generally you can probably just leave this as default,
just hit export animation sequence.
And if we go and find it in our content browser
that we'll click that to open up,
you can see that our animation is playing here.
Saved as its own animation sequence
and we don't need that sequence
or the control rig to play this.
So now that we know how to create a new animation,
let's take a look at how we might be able
to either edit an existing animation
or maybe blend some animations together
to again, create a new animation.
So inside our sequence,
I'm just going to delete our control rig
because if you have a control rig and animations
for a character in a sequence at the same time,
the control rig is going to take priority
and you're not going to be able
to see what animation is playing.
Unless of course you're using a layered control rig,
which we'll touch on in just a few minutes.
So I'm going to right click this
and just press delete.
And you see that a character goes back
to their default pose.
So underneath our Manny character here,
we have an animation track.
Now, if that's something
that's not automatically populated,
you could hit this little plus on your character track.
You could go to the animation tab here
and you could just find an animation and just add that in.
So I could just choose idle, for example,
and that would give us a new animation track.
And then the idle animation is just playing.
So I'm just going to delete this other one.
You could also add the plus on this animation here
and that'll give you the same options.
So it could pick something else
and you can actually see that
you can have multiple animation tracks
playing at the same time.
So you could have multiple animations
laid on top of one another playing at the same time.
But what I'm going to do is just delete
that second animation track.
And I'm going to zoom out a little bit
because our animation is actually longer
than our timeline here.
So we can remedy that quite easily
by just grabbing this end point
and just dragging it along a bit.
So now if I hit space bar,
you can see that our animation
is playing on our character here.
Now, if we want to create a new animation,
say for example, we want to create like a walk start,
what I could do here,
if I scrub past the end of this animation
and then hit the plus on the animation track,
we could search for a walk forward.
And then once we scrub over this,
we can see that this plays after our idle.
So I can actually blend these two animations together
by just overlapping the two animations.
I zoom in a little bit to get a bit better control
by just overlapping these animations.
And you can see that automatically
we get a blend created.
Now, when we scrub over this,
you can see that it blends from the idle
into that walk forward.
And it gives us a sort of walk start
or at least something where you can start off
with a base of animation and then tweak it
if you wanted to, to get something a little nicer.
We could then bake this animation out
to its own animation sequence.
And you can see quite quickly,
we've created just a new animation that is a walk start.
Well, what if we wanted to add a bit more
to this animation that wasn't just using
pre-existing animations in the project?
So you can use something called a layered control rig.
Now, this is something that came in
with version 5.4 of the engine.
And it works in a similar way to animation layers.
So if you've used those before,
then this should be quite straightforward.
So on our character,
I can choose the plus icon here,
go to control rig,
and I'll take the layered option at the top here.
And this will show us all the assets,
all of the control rigs that are available
for this character that have the layered feature.
So as soon as I select that,
that'll bring that in.
And if you notice, compared to our previous control rig,
the layered control rig track
is actually a different color.
So it's quite a good indicator
of which kind of control rig you have.
So if I scrub through this now,
you can see that our animation is playing
as well as our control rig being available.
So we can do the same sort of thing here.
Let's just add a wave to the beginning like we did before.
So if I hit the plus and then scrub along a little bit,
go back into local mode for this,
very briefly just bring these guys up.
I mean, you can already see if I hit play
that our animation is still playing underneath
and our new pose on top
is working essentially like an animation layer.
So if I finish off the rest of the wave,
I'm going to go back into world mode there.
Oh, that's maybe not so useful.
Just control Z there.
And we'll just very quickly add a wave to our character.
And I'm going to do the same thing again,
where I selected all of these controls,
press S to set a key,
copy the first key,
and then paste it again to return to our idle pose.
So if I control C, control V the clavicle as well.
So now if I just zoom out a little bit,
when our animation plays,
you can see that we've added this extra wave on top of it.
And then we revert back to the existing animation
and it goes into the walk start that we made before.
And we can do the same thing with this.
If I go back to the top,
if we scrub to the end of the time slider here,
press this little red button
that'll set our playback range,
the end of our playback range
to where our time slider is.
And I can right click,
bake our animation sequence,
call that A underscore wave walk,
hit export to animation sequence.
And again, that's our wave walk just here.
So you can see that our character's waving,
they have the idle animation working underneath it,
and then they blend into the walk.